these are the top five worst fall
turbine asiak performances what are you
doing here ever April Fool
[Laughter]
what I have mean oh you know No
it's good to be back I'm Walter banana
diac and this is top 5 well now that
you've seen me at my worst I think it's
a good time to take a look at the worst
of someone who really enjoyed that list
Zack Snyder has only directed seven
feature films with his eighth Justice
League slated for a November release in
his relatively short career as a feature
film director Snyder has polarized many
moviegoers with his unique style that
some love and some hate I think we can
all agree he has at least a few decent
films to his name but what are his worst
movies thus far and do they dictate
where his career is heading a good way
to predict the future is to look at the
past so let's do it these are the top 5
worst Zack Snyder movies number 5 Man of
Steel so my opinion has evolved quite a
bit since this movie first came out in
this modern origin story for Superman we
see a more detailed destruction of
Krypton that leads into Cal's presence
on earth and outcast for his whole life
Clark Kent has wandered the world as an
adult keeping a low profile and
searching for his purpose however when
he's needed Clark jumps into action to
save the day but quickly moves on after
upon finally discovering who he is and
where he's from
Clark inadvertently triggers the arrival
of General Zod and his army who are
searching for a new world to inhabit as
the last remaining Kryptonian Zod
betrayed and murdered Clark's birth
father jor-el before Krypton's
destruction now the house of El rises
once again in Superman as he defends the
Earth from these ruthless invaders when
I first saw this movie I kind of thought
it was okay however as time went on my
opinion on it got worse and worse the
flaws just stuck out to me the more I
watched it upon watching it again for
this list I can't say that I've just
accepted what it is those things that I
hated before I still have issues with
but I guess I'm just numb to most of
them now I will say I always really
liked Russell Crowe as jor-el I think
he's my favorite part of the movie at
least he's better than Clark's earth dad
what was I supposed to do but I'm dying
maybe the whole portrayal of Johnson
Kent in this movie is just way off
that's one of the issues that still bugs
me about this film
michael shannon is odd was fun you can
tell he's just cutting loose and most of
his teams as he worked as the character
pretty well plus he created one of my
all-time favorite means by the ideas
presented here are interesting but
executed poorly how would the world
react if superman was real it is an
intriguing question one that the movie
heavily hinges on with its dark and
somber tone
the problem is superman has always
worked best when he's not operating in a
dark or somber world this movie is
trying so hard to be an edgy not your
father's version of Superman they forgot
a lot of what made the character work in
the first place a perfect example of
this is how well Tyler hoechlin Superman
was received on the CW Supergirl show
that's a modern interpretation that I
can get me on and Henry Cavill is not
the problem here I think it's got the
potential to be a really good Superman
he's just handcuffed by the material
he's given everyone keeps saying just
wait he'll be the bright Superman once
he comes back in Justice League then
destroying metropolis killing Zod and
every other questionable thing he's done
will make sense
well the balls in your court Snyder is
that the direction we're going in with
this iteration of Superman we'll find
out in November number four Watchmen do
I hate Watchmen no I don't it has its
moments as well as its vehement
supporters and passionate haters so why
did it make this list when former crime
fighter the comedian is murdered an old
teammate of his Rorschach uncovers a
conspiracy to kill and/or discredit any
and all superheroes both past and
present as he dig deeper he involves his
other former companions to find out
what's happening the truth is not an
easy pill to swallow in this adaptation
of Alan Moore's classic 1987 collected
comic series I've heard the debates
I've seen the detailed articles on why
this movie is a masterpiece and watch
the reviews tearing it apart my issue
with it is besides the visuals it's just
not very interesting I know Snyder went
way out of his way to make sure this
adaptation stuck to the comics as close
as possible but maybe that's part of the
issue it seems like we missed a lot more
interesting stuff that happened before
this story started I know everything is
much more fleshed out in the graphic
novel and from what I've heard this
would have made a much better miniseries
than Moo
too bad Netflix wasn't what it is today
back in oh not a big point of contention
I hear about a lot is the ending this is
your spoiler warning Justin kicks in the
movie Adrienne destroys an entire city
and murders millions of people for what
he says is the greater good a comic book
villain the world will unite against a
common enemy and enter a time of peace
he thinks and the comics a giant squid
monster attacks New York to accomplish
pretty much the same thing the end
result is the same so does it affect the
story all that much
I like Jackie Earle Haley as Rorschach
but other than him the cast just didn't
do it for me and I failed to connect
with anyone
my disinterest in the characters led to
a lack of investment in the movie and
it's just a chore for me to sit through
it does look really good though number
three Batman V Superman dawn of Justice
disclaimer I'm only going to be
referring to the theatrical cut here yes
the extended edition is superior but
we're looking at the initial version of
this film that was released around the
world in March of last year due to the
destruction of Metropolis at the hands
of Zod and Superman many people around
the world including Bruce Wayne think of
Superman as a threat to humanity
Batman decides the only way to protect
the earth is to destroy this threat
meanwhile Lex Luthor enacts his own plan
to take down the Man of Steel this movie
still feels like a big old mess to me
it's not all bad of course as usual
dividuals snyder creates our top notch
and we even get a little more color here
than a Man of Steel then asked like
Batman and gal gadot's Wonder Woman also
stick out as strong positives from this
movie I don't know about you but I'm
pretty excited for the Wonder Woman film
Batman V Superman struggles when trying
to juggle too many things at once it's
trying to introduce new characters at
Batman fights Superman set up the
Justice League movie be a sequel to Man
of Steel and more all at the same time
it's basically crushed under its own
weight now Jesse Eisenberg's Lex Luthor
was whether he's trying to be the real
Alexis son or not a big target for
points against this movie at least he
made a strong choice but he's pretty
unbearable in this role the red capes
circling because that is paradoxical and
[Music]
another thing that ticked me off was the
handling of doomsday
aside from literally looking like crap
doomsday is wasted a character that is
such a big part of the Superman lore and
responsible for his death in the comics
for a while should have gotten an on
screen adaptation that lived up to the
impact he had here he's just a generic
monster created from Lex and God's DNA
cavil also turned in a performance that
wasn't even up to snuff with how he was
in Man of Steel the Matis did very good
it's a two-and-a-half-hour movie that
feels like five hours and one that will
have you yelling for your mommy to make
it
[Applause]
[Music]
number two legend of the guardians the
owls of ga'hoole this is Snyder's only
animated project it's about the rise of
the legend of the guardians of the
galaxy based on the fantasy book series
by Kathryn Lasky legend of the Guardians
follows the young owl Sauron who with
his brother is kidnapped by the evil
Pure Ones a group of owls who look to
unite all the different species and rule
owl kind after Sauron escapes he seeks
the aid of the mythical guardians who
have defeated the Pure Ones in the past
together with his hero Sauron looks to
save all the captured owls and make a
few legends of his own along the way the
movie manages to be boring and still
feels rushed with a lot of Snyder's
trademarks and pacing issues I believe
this adapted a few of the books in the
series into one story and the result
isn't good everything just moves too
fast we never get a strong grasp on
these characters as they're introduced
then quickly thrust into extreme
situations the animation and character
models here are very pretty to look at
they seemingly have very realistic owl
movement which is interesting to see but
it falls into a weird area the animation
is so realistic that we aren't able to
see a very wide range of expressions
from the models I think the movie may
have benefited from a slightly more
cartoony look oh by the way Owl City
contributed to the soundtrack because ow
[Music]
there ends up being some decent action
towards the end but that doesn't make up
for the undeniably dull nature of this
movie once again it's a world that had
potential but it just wasn't reached
with the way this film was presented at
least we get to see some Schneider
slow-mo here though unfortunately it's
much more of a Miss than a hit for
Galaxy guardians legends on the ride
wait and the number one worst that
Snyder movie is sucker punch let's be
honest this probably isn't a surprise to
you after being blamed for the death of
her little sister baby doll is committed
to a mental ward by her abusive
stepfather thinking the real
circumstances surrounding her sister's
death will come to light baby doll
stepfather makes an agreement with an
orderly to have her lobotomize evading
reality baby doll fantasizes about
escaping her situation with the other
girls being held at the asylum here's a
direct quote for mr. Schneider about
Sucker Punch a while ago I had written a
script for myself and there was a
sequence in it that made me think how
can I make a film that can have action
sequences in it that aren't limited to
the physical realities that normal
people are limited by but still have the
story makes sense so it's not and I
don't mean to be mean like a bullshit
thing like ultraviolet or something like
that now I heard a lot of bad things
about this movie and avoided seeing it
when it was in theaters upon watching
it's not quite as bad as I was expecting
but it's still pretty much garbage I was
confused for a bit because I didn't know
baby doll had fantasies within fantasies
when we first see the dance club
scenario start to play out it took me a
moment to catch on it's not like the
outlandish and over-the-top action
scenes that are in the trailers those
come a bit later
they're loud crazy and filled with the
most Snyder II Snyder isms I've ever
seen it was the point where this started
to look like a parody of a Zack Snyder
film with the amount of famous tracks
that accompany his movies I feel like
he'd be the greatest music video
director of all time or if he just made
trailers no one will be able to touch
him as usual everything looks great that
really has the eye for composition in
his shots and I can't criticize him for
that all got Glenn and Oscar Isaac show
up in this movie
I always like to see sky cleanse so that
was nice and Oscar Isaac is a really
good actor too
he has a few decent scenes sprinkle in
there you have anything to say anything
woo-wee
sweetheart okay love the guy liner -
bottom line is the story's trying to say
something and empower these girls but I
don't think it does that do you aside
from nice visuals this really doesn't
have any substance yet I have a feeling
Zak really thought he was making
something great with this personally
most of Snyder's movies have left me
with a sense of potential but often too
many wrong choices are made because of
misunderstandings or just neglect
regarding the characters he has become
responsible for hopefully he corrects
these reoccurring issues with a Justice
League movie that does those characters
well justice I want to hear what you
guys think what is your favorite and or
least favorite Zack Snyder movie will
Justice League be good leave a comment
and let me know make sure you subscribe
to my personal channel youtube.com slash
awesome Walter for more videos from
wrestling to Power Rangers follow me on
Twitter to take part in polls about what
may be covered in the future come back
next week for a brand new episode of top
[Music]
not cool I will be back like my words